dea
今から日本語のレッスンを行います
ゴールデンウィークの過ごし方渋滞に引っかかる朝のコーヒーをズボンにこぼす
インフルエンザにかかる古着を10円で売る知り合いの知り合いの仕事の書類を翻訳
する
スターバックスで列に並ぶレストランで列に並ぶお寺で
列に並ぶ神社で列に並ぶいわゆるパワースポットで列に並ぶ出勤する
残業する大きな diy プロジェクトやっとやり出してすぐに諦め心配する布団
義務的な飲み会ですね微妙なネットフリックスシリーズを全部見る葬式に参列する洗剤
を買うさらに太るずっと話していないフェイス僕のと
私に東京いやいや案内する展望台で視線を一組で遮られる
これを吹く旅先で恋人とケンカ別れやする好きじゃない人のためにお土産を買うバスに
乗り遅れる
電車に乗り遅れ飛行機に乗り遅れん布団洗って外に干しそしてベランダから落として
しまうスパゲッティを茹ですぎるチキンを生焼けにする普段より高いね
残念ものを他人と政治について口玄関する親知らずを抜いてもらおうスマホと銀行に
行くと思ったらガソリンが足りないことに気づくガソリンスタンドに向かう途中で事故
に遭うつまり電話するために知らない人のスマホを借りる知らない人のスマホを落とす
神経衰弱に陥る大しておいしくないかけで食中毒にかかる階段に転ぶ大腿骨を骨折する
病院に行く末期がんを発覚する
翌年のゴールデンウィークのことを考えまた youtube の動画を作る
ni